Okay, so now we have all
the pieces of our puzzle.
The question of course is how we're
going to find those weights w and
those biases b that will get our
classifier to do what we want it to do.
That is, have a low distance for
the correct class but
have a high distance for
the incorrect class.
One thing you can do is measure that
distance averaged over the entire
training sets for all the inputs and
all the labels that you have available.
That's called the training loss.
This loss, which is the average
cross-entropy over your entire training
set, Is one humongous function.
Every example in your training set gets
multiplied by this one big matrix W.
And then they get all
added up in one big sum.
We want all the distances to be small,
which would mean we're
doing a good job at classifying
every example in the training data.
So we want the loss to be small.
The loss is a function of
the weights and the biases.
So we are simply going to try and
minimize that function.
Imagine that the loss is
a function of two weights.
Weight one and weight two.
Just for the sake of argument.
It's going to be a function which
will be large in some areas, and
small in others.
We're going to try the weights which
cause this loss to be the smallest.
We've just turned
the machine learning problem
into one of numerical optimization.
And there's lots of ways to solve
a numerical optimization problem.
The simplest way is one you've probably
encountered before, gradient descent.
Take the derivative of your loss,
with respect to your parameters, and
follow that derivative by
taking a step backwards and
repeat until you get to the bottom.
Gradient descent is relatively simple,
especially when you
have powerful numerical tools that
compute the derivatives for you.
Remember, I'm showing
you the derivative for
a function of just two parameters here,
but for a typical problem
it could be a function of thousands,
millions or even billions of parameters.